hi all thanks for coming i'm going to do
a survey it's all called
exploration it's like
a line of work with a bunch of
collaborators and
now there is a survey in the textbook
okay so what is this about uh well the
key question is this
how do you incentivize self-interested
agents to explore
when they selfishly prefer to exploit
i mean here agents are like users in
recommendary systems and of course this
is like a widespread application
scenario because you know documentary
systems are everywhere and the ability
to do good recommendations is essential
in many parts
so slightly more technically is going to
be about you know bandits and agents
uh even more slightly technically it
will be about bandits with division
persuasion and in a few slices i'll
explain what it means
so it's like
higher level is like one nice way to
combine exploration and incentives and i
just wanted to point out that there are
several other interesting ways in which
you know exploration plays out in
strategic environments for and like one
useful way to sort of
tell these ways apart
is to see
like what is like which aspects of the
model are controlled by the agents so
say if agents control bids that's like
repeated options like you know dynamic
pricing uh agents only effective words
uh in like platform cooking the tuition
models uh like users may be choosing
among platforms running combined
algorithms but in incentives exploration
agents uh
control the choice of actions
okay so let's dig in a little bit
so
let's look at sort of idealized
model of information flow in the
recommender system so what happens is
that like a use a user arrives need to
choose needs to choose a product
okay receive the recommendation and
maybe some extra information like
ratings and whatnot
and then you know chooses a product and
leave some feedback
well so okay what's going on here is
that like
on one hand
uh
this user consumes information from the
previous users
through recommendations and on the other
hand it produces information for the
future users
pointer visible
okay so you see here there is some
explore exploit trade-off going on here
and for the sake of the common good the
user population would like to balance
this exploration exploitation
for example they could be coordinated
through a systems recommendation if a
system could tell people what to do
well
not quite because incentives are
misaligned because self-interested users
are like you know agents that
would like to exploit
rather than explore
and you know as a result some actions
may be explored at suboptimal rate and
you know some actions could remain
unexplored and like in the kind of
idealized worst case
uh best action may remain completely
unexplored if it seems worse initially
so like a bunch of things
could go wrong
okay so let's put some more concrete
model
to this
so okay say we have t rounds and k
actions also called arms in each round
what happens is that a new agent shows
up observes something like whatever it
observes uh then chooses an arm and
reports a reward
well let's keep things simple let's say
that rewards are iad meaning the reward
of
each uh arm is drawn
independently from some distribution
specific to this arm and this this
distribution
is fixed over time but it's not known
and let's put
a common beijing prayer just to make
sure that like you know everybody's
beliefs are all different
okay
let's say the objective was social
welfare in other words cumulative reward
of all the agents
like what do the agents do actually well
a rational choice for each agent would
be to choose whichever arm that seems
best
given whatever the agent knows
in expectation of the trial
so okay that's what the agents do
okay
that's kind of the model but note that
we have something unspecified
this pointer i don't see the point
i'll show so the
message okay i do see it sometimes
so uh the message what is the message
well the default is that each
agent sees full history
and now this is like
it corresponds to i mean you know seeing
for history and making a rational choice
could respond to something well-known
invented it's called like greedy
algorithm where like you don't explore
you just explore it or more precisely
it's like bayesian version of the greedy
algorithm
okay
what could go wrong with greedy i mean
why don't we just do that so again
in each round this algorithm just
exploits given the current history
so
it's kind of instructive to see what
goes wrong
so okay uh
let's keep things simple there are just
two arms with the media words me one and
me two
and like let's look at this entire gap
like you know gap between the one and
you two and expectation over the prior
and let's say
arm one looks better initially well
what's going to happen in round one is
that you need to choose our mod
okay now let's keep things really simple
if the words are deterministic then mu
one is observed
but then if mu 1 is better than prior
mean reward of the other arm then the
other arm just never gets chosen this is
like a big timer inferior
okay
what about randomized rewards well maybe
you know
and like randomness in the words would
allow us to explore
well
it turns out no in fact like
rm2 is never chosen with
some constant probability and like uh
the probability is actually the
prior gap
and this is also kind of a big time
learning failure and in particular one
could show that like beijing regret of
this algorithm is going to be linear in
time under some
mild fine print
uh
interestingly like you'd
think search result would be known for
many decades because like it's like you
know why do i need to explore and i
thought so too and at some point i
needed it and i
looked around i couldn't find it i asked
around a lot i couldn't find it i tried
to prove it i couldn't prove it
and
it was kind of awesome and then i asked
mark so can he prove that
so like now it exists
um okay so let's go back
uh so okay we really need to explore we
really need to incentivize exploration
okay so how do we incentivize agents to
take actions that seem suboptimal given
like
their initial biases and given what the
algorithm knows now
well
there are some external incentives like
one could offer payments or discounts or
one could promise you know higher social
status like you'll get a medium page if
you do a good job
or just some people just like to
experiment
well one could rely on any of that and
it's fine but but like it's prone to
selection bias right and just like i
don't know will
the people who will explore will be the
people who are more sensitive to money
or who are like more vain or who are
more like adventurous right and it's
also just not always feasible because
maybe you don't have money or something
uh
okay so that's not what we do
and instead our approach is to create
information asymmetry by not revealing
full history
and then we like use that information i
see we try to create incentives in other
words the algorithm will know more than
anyone use
okay so let's go back to the model
that's exactly what we had before so
there are like messages the default was
a full history but it doesn't work so
instead what do we do well now the
messages are going to be chosen by the
algorithm
okay
we can actually simplify it a little bit
so one can prove that without loss of
general let's see
the message could be just a suggested
arm
and then
the whole algorithm will need to satisfy
a condition called data and incentivized
compatibility asset based incentive
compatibility
which essentially says that each user
is better off following recommendations
so
okay and now the model got kind of
simpler in that like it's just a bended
algorithm with an extra constraint and
the constraint is about in sentence and
conveniently
what we can compare like what happens
with these bic bandit algorithms see
what happens with just like bandit
algorithms
okay
and
there is a bunch of work on this over
several years
uh the home community has been mostly
acme easy
and i mean
it's kind of
hopeless to expose the stuff linearly so
instead i will sort of dissect it in
several different ways the rest of the
talk
uh and like i will touch upon these
papers you know i'll glossing over a
bunch of stuff
and by the way do ask if something is
not
okay
i have a wonderful plan for the rest of
the talk which consists of related work
basic stuff advanced stuff and open
questions
okay so uh i think it's kind of
interesting to see like to kind of zoom
out a little bit and see where
incentivized exploration sits in the
well slightly grander scheme of things
and it happens to sit in the
intersection of
vandals and use through the important
sub areas of economics for theoretical
dynamics social learning and information
design so
social learning is like
agents learn over time in a shared
environment
and typically there is like no principle
or and like agents are there on their
own
uh most related
like there are like many models they're
the most related one called
strategic experimentation deposits that
like agents are like long lived like
learn over time each agent can explore
and exploit but of course each agent
prefers to freeride an exploration done
by the others but
they do they derive optimal
policies in a very scary way
and like analyze
anyway uh i compare it to all this work
uh what we do can be framed as like
social learning with a mediator because
like you know
we have a bunch of agents and a shared
environment collectively they need to
learn something
and there is immediate
other algorithm
as far as information design see one
round of our model is this very well
known
model in a
a theoretical economics called vision
persuasion which i guess
many of you know so
in a natural
sender gets a it's like a game between
two players sender and the receiver
sender gets a private signal chooses a
message for the receiver and then like
receiver observes that and chooses an
action and the sender wants to get the
receiver to choose
like what sender wants
uh the the focus in that work is usually
on like deriving
optimal policies for this one round game
i mean optimal for the sample
in comparison so
for us the sender is an algorithm
and the signal is the history of the
algorithm up to this round the objective
is different their
objective is like you know our objective
is like trade-off explore and exploit
so
uh
one could sort of fit filtered into the
model vision persuasion in a kind of
very myopic way it's like what if
initially are one is
preferred and all we want is to try arm
two
in the next round well then we could say
okay what if the center is utility is
just one if arm if rm2 is chosen and
zero otherwise so
it kind of maps but a long term
objective of explore exploit tradeoff it
doesn't i seem to fit in
into the standard model here so in other
words we do something
although related
okay
let me mention kind of three closely
related lines of work
uh
one line of work recently is about how
like greedy algorithms sometimes work
pretty well
but you need to assume some structure
it's like kind of strong assumptions
about structure
for example like linear rewards and like
very heterogeneous agents
and in a way this this structure that
you assume it kind of substitutes for
explicit exploration
another line of work is like okay you
like weeds exploration with through
information but you could do it with
money
and like uh there is very
nice line of work on that
and in all this work uh a all agents
observe a full history
so like
the only lever in this work with which
they
incentivize is the money whereas for us
the only lever is information
and uh finally online vision persuasion
which on which
uh
there was a talk earlier today
um
it's kind of another model combining you
know online algorithms like over time
and bearing persuasion in each round
but the
it's getting very different the key
distinction i think is that in each
round the signal of the algorithm is iad
whereas for us it's algorithms history
so it's like it changes over time and
kind of grows over time depending on on
the algorithm's actions in the past
also
to my understanding like what makes this
problem interesting and non-trivial is
the incentives
so it's like without incentives there is
no problem it's all about weak
incentives
and for us of course if you remove
incentives
what's left is a bandit problem okay
so
uh
let's go do some basic stuff about our
model now
uh
so it's kind of
let's kind of ground ourselves into some
technical bit to see that there is like
something immediately non-trivial going
on on top of bandits
so let's look at the prior
and let's observe the in general it's
like for iris like there are priors for
which the problem is completely hoped
in the sense that like
you will
never try arm 2 ever
for example if like arm 1 is looks
better initially and like the prior is
such that mu1 and u1 minus mu2 are
independent
well initially you need to try arm one
fine but like no matter how much data
you get about nu1 you will know nothing
about me one minus mu2 so you will never
try rm2
okay it means that we need some
assumptions on the prior
so as we prove
there is a sufficient condition for two
arms which basically says that like
up if we have enough samples of arm one
arm two can become the best one
so to put it to make it slightly more
technical it's like let's look at
something called posterior gap which is
like
gap
between the two arms in expectation of
the samples
so
anyway sorry in expectation given the
samples
so it is a random variable
and the condition is that
this random variable should be should be
strictly positive with some positive
probabilities and like under this
condition we can explore armies with it
turns out
moreover this condition is necessary
it's like without it we will we actually
will not sample
m2 and there is a well not that it's
super important to the stuff but the
proof is very simple it's like you could
you know
massage expectations and see if you know
if it's false you know the ac condition
will never
work in our favor
okay and now
it's for so
for two arms we'll know exactly what's
going on for uh more than two arms it's
not quite clear we have a kind of
similar condition which is uh
sufficient and this condition
includes sort of the predigmatic case
when the prior is independent across
arms and there was a bound and they
might have full support so it's like
okay
in the predict mighty case we can do
stuff
okay
uh
what are the basic techniques so i guess
usually
people talk about like rewards then
techniques i will switch the order like
what can we do in this setting
well the most basic and like
simultaneously the most general thing
one could do is something called hidden
exploration so the idea is that we hide
a little bit of exploration in a whole
lot of exploitation right
well precisely in each round we like you
know
go wild do whatever we
want with some a small probability that
depends on the prior
and otherwise we exploit given what we
know
and the point is that like
the
agent doesn't know which branch we're in
the agent knows that like most likely we
exploit and we exploit given more
information that the agent knows so kind
of
there is a possibility that
the agent is in the exploration range
but on the balance is better to it's
better it's a full recommendation
and like one needs to adjust the
probability kind of make it low enough
to make that happen
so in fact this is a general reduction
in the sense that like one could take
any algorithm and like you know instead
of just go wild step just like
i mean the most
basic version is just like
play arm two but actually one could take
any algorithm and like when you like go
wild you you know
like advance a step of this algorithm
so
you kind of take an algorithm and make
it bac but you lose
because of this
effect
okay uh another technique that
works
is this
well-known algorithm called a successive
elimination
the idea is like
you maintain a set of active arms you
iterate among them
until you can eliminate one of them with
high probability
and then you continue
however one needs to modify it to kind
of make the confidence balance larger
because of incentives and like
because of that you're kind of losing
the performance a bit
uh
the benefit of this algorithm is that it
does not
need to know the prior like it's
possible to like make it happen
if you only know like two parameters
about the prior and like only know them
approximately so it's like in reality
you don't really know the prior and the
prior is kind of fictional anyway but
it's a financial just know these
parameters and then like
you know this algorithm would handle
any
fire that
sort of is consistent with these
parameters and in fact different agents
could have different priorities as long
as they're consistent with these
parameters
okay and uh finally uh thompson sampling
works as is which is cool it's like a
standard algorithm it works
uh
if the prior in terms of sampling is the
actual prior
okay some caveats
well the last two algorithms uh
successful elimination types of sampling
they really need
independent priorities and like beyond
that we need to go back to hidden
exploration
another caveat is that each algorithm
needs some initialization so it needs to
be initialized with some amount of data
some number of samples of each arm
however that number of samples uh
depends only on the prior so it's like
you know the way we usually think about
regret bounds is like a function of uh
time of the time horizon well this is
like a consulate in the time horizon it
depends under the prior
and the way we collect that is by a
version of hidden exploration
okay so with these techniques what do we
prove
well okay we get
we can use hidden exploration and get
optimal bayern regret well okay optimal
in time
for a constant number of arms it is
exponential in k the number of arms
which you know could be just the price
of exploration like uh sorry it could be
the price of incentives
it's like you know
for bandits it's like a root of kt but
now it's exponential but i'll get to
that in a
little later but in t it's optimal
uh
for independent priors we could get
optimal frequencies regret using
successive elimination and again it's
like optimal in time for a constant
number of arms
and with uh thompson sampling we could
get optimal base and regret like really
for any k except well we need these
initial samples of each environment to
collect them we again need to facing
okay so that's the basic stuff
and we need to like blow up the
continents bounce quite a bit
okay
uh
we can go to some advanced stuff and
like which i think like
which questions can we ask well
it turns out there are a bunch
uh even in the basic model we could ask
okay what should really be the
dependence on the number of arms and the
price
dependence on the priors like which
parameters should we be thinking about
also like
just like in usual bandits we could
think about regret or or we could think
about pure exploration
so like here the goal of pure
exploration is to explore you know all
explorable arms that is like all arms
that
it's like you know it's not necessarily
true that any arm can be explored by a
bac algorithm so it's like some arms
but we want to explore all arms that can
be explored
now
like on top of that we could extend
their like learning model
underneath the
problem so like so far it was kind of
the most basic model of bandits
well okay we could ask how about the
more complicated uh problems like what
if we have uh extra feedback like
in contextual bandits
or like what if the problem is like a
large structured horrible thing like in
our epistemic real for example
thirdly
if we talk about extending the
kind of economic part of the model in
several ways like what if agents are
heterogeneous i mean say like what if
agent has a type which is like private
or uh public whatnot what could ask many
questions like that
what if there are multiple agents in
each round then they play a game
affecting one another
for example if it's like
like
waze recommends driving directions to
asians well
you know
drivers affect each other on the road
because they create congestion
and thirdly like
we make kind of
standard but very strong economic
assumptions
that if you think about them they're
kind of iffy and like what if we try to
relax
okay so in the rest of the talk i will
touch upon you know like one example of
you know these three things
um
how am i doing on time by the way
awesome okay
so
okay so
uh
in the basic models like let's ask okay
what is the price of incentives in other
words like
what is the loss in performance in some
sense compared to your optimal
algorithms in bandits without incentive
constraints
more specifically let's focus on kind of
pure exploration example complexity
question
so like how many rounds do we need to
explore each of each arm once in a way
it's like the most basic question you
could ask
you know
forget about regret i just want to see
each arm once
and okay let's
think about things that are like
independent priors
uh and like you know for each arm the
prior comes from some family of priors
so
the result is that
it's about like exponential versus
linear dependence on
k the number of worms so
remember in the basic results we were
getting exponential dependence
and like it was not clear is this really
a price of incentives or not well it
turns out
there is a sharp
dichotomy so like depending on that
family
the kind of optimal number of rounds
here is either linear or exponential
it's like nothing in between
and for a sort of standard examples you
would think of it's actually linear
it's like beta priors or
translated gaussians like
the first and main things you would
think of when you mod when you think
about beijing inference
is linear
okay
but
how do things depend on on the beliefs
in the prior
well
what is the part
what is the right parameter it seems to
be the sentence the strength of the
beliefs is like how strong is my belief
that you know
the the
reward of this arm is approximately this
well
it's all about the variance of the prior
so roughly it's like look at the
smallest variance
oh that's kind of the key parameter well
it turns out that it needs to be
exponential in that so it's like not
good but it has to do that
so that's really the price
and like note that all this complexity
happens even with like basic banded
problem with the two arms
okay uh the algorithm that achieves that
is kind of tricky it's kind of like
starts with hidden exploration but then
in hidden exploration there are like two
branches you know explore like doing
whatever you want or exploit
here there are three branches explore
exploit and some kind of a secret source
third branch combining both in some
fairly
tricky way and crucially the kind of
aggregate result of that is that the
exploration
probability increases exponentially over
time and that's the key driver that like
allows us to get from like exponential
dependence and hidden exploration
exponential dependence on k in hidden
exploration to linear dependence
okay
that's
that for this extension
yes
you're assuming independent price all
these systems oh yes yes yes well uh we
need to assume that the players
find that are
independent across actions otherwise we
cannot do this
without independence we can do something
with the different exploration and and
like
for two arms we have a nested
insufficient condition like i said so
it's like you know you know exactly
what's going on and we can do it
[Music]
when it is
possible
so
that's the statement
but
does any of this stuff
you consider the t is a part of the k
out of the kind of
players
but you know if players are demanding
the cross arms it's
not okay
when you talk about dichotomy uh do you
mean that there is a characterization of
which distributions submit linear
and that that does not satisfy women yes
[Music]
let me give example another extension
like when we extend the brain model
right so
specifically let's
let's tackle kind of you know a
predigmatic hard running problem of
incentives uh sorry i like beside the
car
reinforcement learning and like you know
most of you
know what episodic rl is so and like i
can't like really like explain it
properly so i won't even try
uh you know it's all about mdps
and um
you know what happens in
our model of it is that in each episode
the new agent arrives
observes a mess some message chosen by
our algorithm
and then chooses a policy in a
self-interested way
and that policy
stays for the entire episode
so uh we only tackle a pure exploration
version which is like you know visitors
things
obviously speaking
that
can
possibly be reached by some
rl algorithm so it's like we just want
to visit everything that
can be visited
okay uh
what makes it complicated is that like
from the point of view of like
incentives exploration the actions here
are policies
and there's like a huge number of
policies and you know
participators having the correlator so
it's like
it makes it complicated
you know we'd like to avoid you know
exponential dependence on the policy
space for example
so we do something here which kind of
avoids that very dependence and like the
details of the results are kind of
tedious but let me mention the technique
which is a little more interesting which
is something that we call hidden
hallucination so here essentially the
message is algorithms history and like
in this episode like
most of the time we show
uh
true history so then the agent exploits
or can exploit
or else we show kind of a hallucinated
history so it's like we artificially
generate rewards
to promote exploration
namely we just look at like all the
stuff that was visited before and we
make it look bad
the key point here is that like
we're not telling the agents exactly
what to do
we just i tell them hey you know try
something new
you know same reason as for hidden
exploration just like
most of the time it's exploitation so on
the balance the agents want to follow
recommendations
but you know
they every once in a while they will
explore
uh the technical details are kind of
very hairy
human exploration but it's kind of a
property of
reinforcement learning any
proof there is complicated for some
reason
if the objective is pure exploration why
exploit it
why why exploit the probability one
minuscule
so it's the objective of our algorithm
but
we need to create incentives for the
agents so each agent wants to exploit it
each agent will exploit given whatever
message that we show
why would the agent trust us
well most of the time we show
full history
but is that just a nice property of the
algorithm yeah
it's not it's not what we
need to say just like
it means to the goal
but yeah
the goal is to exploration like you know
one could
use that data to explore it afterwards
and get something like this
[Music]
statistically
that's a great point so the
like
most of the complexity that can clear
here is that we need to we need to make
it
possible
okay
so here you will be like history
[Music]
that's uh you know
that argument requires like knowing the
fire
so
it's like an algorithm could potentially
do that
a reason of like thinking about the
representation of the message and you
don't want to have something that takes
all states and those accidents
like policy
but maybe
so
here it's just a convenient
representation i'm like whatever i say
about like oh
awesome
here is just a convenient representation
for the truth
anything that i say about like oh
is really important
agents could talk to each other
so
in general if you
like like even independent model
it's very important that the
algorithm controls that
information and like
if there is some information that like
escapes and is
observed will never work really messes
us up
what i mean like
there are ways to deal with that a
little bit but yeah it's a big headache
uh
so the third and
oh yeah
i don't know for sure but
to invest in my knowledge it happens to
be the first
a third the final extension that i
wanted to
talk about is about relaxing uh economic
assumptions
and like
kind of standard and we don't even think
about them it's like okay but then like
if you think about it
so okay
there is this thing called power it's
committed to the algorithm it's like the
you know
principle can commit to whatever it's
doing and like
you know it's kind of iffy it's like do
i
like
more than that the agents like need to
know the algorithm to do better now like
do i know the algorithm do i
trust the platform to like
implement the algorithm that they
announce and like
even if they want to do it do i trust
them to like not mess it up i actually
don't trust them
then like uh there are cognitive
limitations it's like
you want agents to think about beijing
updates so can they do it
do i as a user want to do it i don't
want to worry about it i mean one way to
like mitigate that is to think like oh
you know
somebody else will tell me that
there is a proof
there is a proof and you need to follow
recommendations
because you know such
a theorem says that the algorithm is
basic
i mean will i trust that proof is a user
like probably
not
i'm like i won't even understand what it
is so it's like kind of if
moreover there is the thing about
traditional choices like
i assume that people just optimize
expected utility but like what if they
don't there is there is a whole lot of
stuff about like risk conversion or like
soft max versus hard marks
also sometimes people may be averse to
being experimented it's like you know
maybe it's all
you know bic it's all you know i'm
supposed to power it but i just don't
like it so i will just leave the
platform
so okay in the face of all that how do
you ensure
predictable user behavior it's like you
know we'd like to know what the users
are going to do
control
and like there is no like great answer
set in stone but like we try something
so
here is an attempt through selective
information disclosure so it's like this
like users want to what the users want
is to see the full history
well okay
that's too much it doesn't work let's
try to give them the next
best thing some kind of
some history but not uh full history
more precisely the principal chooses a
partial order on rounds in other words
directly the secret graph one rounds
and uh you know each user sees a full
history of her branch
so it's like you know
i see
what happened to all the rounds that
you know
precede me in the partial order
so
it's kind of nice in that this history
is like
this sub history involves a subset of
rounds that is fixed over time so it's
like no cheating i mean cheating would
be like you know i want user a user to
try arm two there are four i subsample
all rounds which make rm2 look good
okay i'm not doing that i need to fix
all the rounds in the box
and
moreover it's like
the it's like the history that each user
sees could be interpreted as like the
full history of the relevant part of the
algorithm it's like
the rest of the world you know just some
other stuff happening in the world
doesn't concern me but the part of the
algorithm that actually concerns me i
see the full history of that
so the nice well one nice thing that
happens to economic foundation here is
that we only need to assume
uh what users do when they see full
history as opposed to like what users do
when they interact with some crazy
algorithm
also
uh also regarding hard marks versus
softmax well
we could handle either as long as it's
consistent with confidence intervals
so okay we construct some such order and
the key is to construct this order in a
very intricate way but like after it's
done you know
the principle is not doing anything and
just kind of agents kind of learn on
their own
and you know even though each agent is
sort of locally greedy it follows kind
of a greedy algorithm locally but the
whole thing works the system exploits
and
one could do a
kind of
relatively easy construction to get kind
of non-adapted exploration and like
teach you the third regret or like much
more
tricky construction and get rid of
regret
uh how much time do you have what uh
let me conclude with open questions and
uh it's referred to what elan said in
the yesterday's panel i'm not promising
you know
best works in operation directory but i
think they're pretty interesting
i think so like one thing is about
relaxed economic assumptions so it's
like do we have the right ones and like
what does it even mean to have the right
assumptions
also like our constructions are
pretty complicated it can make them like
simpler and like less brittle right
then okay whatever the prior is not for
you known or like
it is showing like maybe what if we can
like refine that knowledge over time
thirdly
well we assumed uh shortly of the agents
you know each agent only lives in one
round
not because it's what happens in life
but because that's what you could handle
like but like what if they're like a
long again
right
uh
next you know as you said like what if
there are inevitable observations
there is a little work on that well some
work on that but like it's still
it's so complicated
and uh finally like
with heterogeneous agents like which are
like we know something but like
which regret bounce it's not it's not
clear and like
it's plausible that like diversity of
agents can be used to help basic
exploration rather than just make our
life difficult in the groups so it's
like all that stuff is still
still pretty open
okay uh thank you
well okay
a
simple construction that
uses for a thrust is somewhat robust
it's like
there are ways you could
mess with it and it stays useful
[Music]
um
okay thank you